this program shows drugs being made sold
and used it features graphic content
that may not be suitable for all
audiences viewer discretion is advised
[Music]
concerned neighbors have made a 9-1-1
call
nothing could prepare police for what
they find
[Music]
i think the individual moved in here
less than a month ago
this is the
third overdose this weekend so i would
say that yes there's a lot of really
good heroin going through the city of
portland right now it's just another
night in the overdose capital of the
pacific northwest
situated on the west coast of northern
oregon portland is one of the greenest
cities in the u.s
its progressive attitudes have made it a
mecca for america's homeless
who come in search of free handouts
you know portland's probably one of the
better places for being homeless and
killer drugs
well the kids are here because
it's the party you don't get in trouble
[Music]
a new generation of addicts is taking
over the streets
their custom is helping fund the
deadliest drug market in the pacific
northwest
if you don't have confidence within
yourself then you're just gonna the
streets are gonna eat you alive
sparky left home at 12
has lived on the streets since 2003. i
actually started doing meth to stay
awake because of the fact of waking up
and i'm scared
for many of these homeless kids
meth is the drug of choice
i was up for 24 days launch i went to
psycho
sparky has been living with her
girlfriend under morrison bridge but
they're desperate to move on
basically somebody tried to be a slick
and
drove off with everything we owned
way to get my hand
as two lone women sparky and a
girlfriend are vulnerable to attacks
this time they've had their sleeping
bags stolen
their only option is to walk the streets
all night
for this they need meth
but when you're homeless finding
somewhere to get high isn't always easy
just the only place they can actually
get away with being in there for like a
couple minutes without anybody seeing
you
actually you don't really feel anything
until like three hits four hits
after five years of meth addiction
sparky has built up a tolerance at first
you get really big head rush just feel
like you can do anything you know like
instead of like running for like three
minutes you can run like an hour
like it's crazy meth users experience
euphoria and increased energy then you
get like a warm fuzzy feeling all over
but it can also bring on intense
paranoia
she's convinced they're being watched
we'll act like we went to the bathroom
ready
[Music]
afraid of getting busted they grab their
stuff and make a quick exit
[Music]
is there like a certain amount of time
we're supposed to be in the bathroom or
something what was going on in there i
was just got done changing clothes
sparky's behavior is suspicious it's
drawn the attention of a park security
officer
the thing is it's like there there's a
lot of
there can be a lot of negative things
that go on oh yeah every bathroom you
can expect something like that
you guys have a place to bump down
tonight or something
no concern for their well-being the
security officer chooses to help them
out
promise me that you will not spend it on
booze or drugs
five bucks on drugs really
sparky's been let off easy
with the cops when it comes to regards
to
like drugs and getting busted this is
he's a kick if you guys don't think it's
chill in portland and
tripping
but in the face of a growing drug
epidemic
portland's relaxed attitudes are
changing
tension between law enforcement and the
homeless has reached boiling point
the bumblebees are sent in to tackle the
problem
officers use mace to control the angry
crowd
once a friendly city
portland now has violence spilling onto
its streets
[Music]
local police are also cracking down on a
drug problem that's gotten out of hand
so this is pioneer square and this is
where a lot of our addicts and dealers
will hang out
[Music]
the street crimes unit is on patrol
keeping the city's drug hot spots under
surveillance
sometimes you'll see somebody walk
through and head nod and you'll see a
group of people follow so they'll go
a couple of blocks where they think they
haven't been seen
and make the deal and then come right
back and do it again
in downtown portland dealers are taking
advantage of cheap public transportation
drug hot spots have mushroomed along the
max train line where dealers make their
deliveries to users
they panhandle here
to make their money to get their drugs
so it's just pretty compact and
convenient
the streets are full of repeat offenders
cops and users are on familiar terms
how many times have i arrested you
i know you you know me rock ass crap
[Music]
tequila and brandon head to one of
portland's tourist spots
a famous donut shop
an informant has revealed that a
notorious meth dealer lives in an
apartment upstairs
so there's going to be a group on our
left
i recognize the man you see that yep
an angry customer has seen the plane
closed unit and blows their cover
how you doing
can i help you no can you can i help you
they're a little bit unhappy with us
right now um because they're dealers not
gonna come down while we're here
under the cops watchful eyes strung out
customers are led into the dealer's
apartment
customers continue to flood to the door
tequila recognizes a regular
she uses mostly meth
desperate for a fix the customer yells
up to the dealer's window
that girl
she's pissing that chick because she
yelled out
with their cover blown
the officers are forced to change
tactics
a second unit takes their place
yeah i'm watching
right now
at the same spot more and more customers
bang on the dealer's door desperate for
a fix
[Music]
as the lure of easy money becomes too
big for the dealer to ignore
the dealer steps out
he's walking the block she's
following it looks like he's
got a group of users following
most likely he's about to go around the
corner and make the deal tequila and
brandon spot him in an alley nearby
in the middle of that little eating area
with a big old gaggle the dealer and his
customers use the tourists as cover
he'll come to and from his apartment
grabbing only what he needs sell that
amount take the money back up
heading back up to uh third
with everybody in tow
without seeing money change hands
the cops can't make an arrest we can try
to pick off one of the people that we
saw walking with him
and we can actually get the drugs we can
help us get in
then a stroke of luck the second unit
spot what looks like a deal
and he's going in his apartment she's
off northbound
i'm gonna follow her
brandon and tequila fall in behind one
of the customers
the girl crosses the street forcing the
officers to abandon their car and pursue
her on foot stop
she doesn't get far as a cycle officer
swoops in
tequila is quick to search her
i haven't had any money i haven't
i haven't bought anything all day
she has no drugs in her possession but
as a known drug user they run a
background check
okay so i'm going to walk you over here
to the car the suspect failed to show up
for treatment on a previous drug charge
and has a warrant out for her arrest
most likely she was fined from our
target
she gave him money he went up to his
apartment i'm sure she was going to have
instruction to meet him somewhere else
and
obviously he didn't catch back up with
her yet policing at this level is a
frustrating process it's not uncommon to
make an arrest and book them into jail
and before we're even done doing our
paperwork they'll be out
you know in hockey when you get a
penalty and you go to the penalty box i
think that's kind of what we do we put
them in the penalty box for their three
minutes and then they're back
the city's relaxed drug policy has left
dealers free to roam the streets
for those with ambition dealing in
portland is a business that rings off
the hook
you have 2
new messages
[Music]
i gotta call this dude man hey
so what do you want to do
crystal seed sells up to four ounces of
meth a day he used to be one of portland
street kids
now he's a big time meth dealer
he's on his way to meet his mexican
supplier in one of portland's suburbs
usually i wouldn't come out here at
three in the morning
i just got a couple people that saw my
ass about it right now
a meth deal of this size is always risky
my boy is smart
he doesn't sell nothing to nobody out
here
so it's not like he's his
in the meth game for over 10 years
crystal seed has seen the business
transform
the best that i've ever done
was always like we had frozen apple
juice it's like cooked here made it and
that's what it came out like
you know
before that way better
portland had a booming industry based on
local labs
[Music]
feds put
a ban on all the silver fishing pills
and that just flipped the whole game
upside down
in 2006 pseudoephedrine became
prescription only
without the key ingredient the local
meth industry disappeared overnight
[Music]
and this opened the door for the cartels
then once they took the pills away it
just all turned into the mexican cartel
cast running it
mexican drug trafficking organizations
linked to the sinaloa and knights
templar cartels have infiltrated
portland monopolizing all supply lines
into the city
you want to have a mexican that's what
you call it they're the best plugs
connections whatever
all right so yeah i need to bounce off
because i'm here to meet my guy
dealers are easy targets for stick up
crews
crystal c changes cars and location
he's using counter surveillance measures
to avoid being tailed
[Music]
from the finest grade eight
bombay math because like big clear
pieces of the cookie cutter image of
what you
see in your mind when somebody said
crystal
[Music]
users associate the crystal shape with
purity and strength
for crystal seed it doesn't compare to
the homegrown portland meth he used to
get
now see with the old dope though
it would keep you longer for more days
you'll see all these like just skeletons
walk around just thinking they're the
fastest the planet
i don't really get weird i
didn't start
doing the chicken around the room or
nothing with a decline in quality
crystal seed sells is dope cheap to keep
the customers coming back
this right here is about
i said it's a little over 16.
some people pay 80 90 bucks for this
i usually charge about 60. just cash out
away from me for days at their money
because they know i'm going to give them
a proper deal
he has no intention of climbing the drug
ladder the mexicans have a tough rep
the higher you get the further you fall
a lot of people want to be known as the
guy with the bag
i've watched the people like on a higher
level of me i've watched them all rotate
and dropping my flies out here
[Music]
the mexican drug cartels have taken over
forcing cops in suburbia to up their
game
rock and roll
we got your equipment yep
just 12 miles from portland across the
washington state line
local task force is moving on to mexican
meth ring
this actually is a pretty dangerous
operation
most people that have their door come
crashing in on them at 5 30 in the
morning are going to be scared
we are going to be very very careful
about
any of these people that arm themselves
in a panic
the drug task force has had this group
of mexicans under surveillance for 10
months
a hidden camera has filmed their every
move
the kingpin of this local operation is
mexican national the ringleader is known
as wad and his operation shifts hundreds
of thousands of dollars worth of meth
every month he runs
his crew of runners out of an auto body
repair type business all of his runners
are mexican nationals
most are illegal immigrants he's
bringing up dope from mexico
they're splitting it up we believe that
these shops and then distributing it
throughout the portland vancouver area
[Music]
today the cops are serving six warrants
on six different locations
the aim to this massive drug
ring in one fell swoop
[Music]
please
cartel members are usually heavily armed
police have to secure the house fast
[Music]
they catch one of the drug runners
asleep but they have no idea what's
waiting for them upstairs
[Music]
it's a full house
with 12 family members downstairs the
house is clear
the two main targets are in cuffs
commander cook calls in the canine unit
this is just the start there are five
other stash locations to hit
we may find money
but more than anything i think here
we'll just find documents of
identification the canine zeros in on
something in the kingpin's bedroom
is found in safe under
our main target's uh bedroom from
looking in there's probably at least
probably 10 to 20 000 in there
in a nearby garden shed
officers make a disturbing discovery
with the walls spattered in blood
bones and feathers are all that remain
of the animals slaughtered on the
sacrificial altar to jesus malverde
[Music]
then here we have
jesus male verdi patron saint of drug
traffickers
our head honcho here our bad guy
is wearing some jewelry around his neck
with
jesus malverde's picture on it so
he's the he's the real deal
now they need to find the drugs to prove
it
while one team searches the drug runners
houses the other focuses on the
distribution hub of the drug ring which
operates out of an auto body repair
business
well we're hoping to find dope in here
because all the buys we've done the
dopest come from these shops directly
out to the buy location and then the
runners come back to the shop
the workshop was also used to prepare
cars for trafficking drugs
to access the trap in this vehicle the
driver needs to perform a series of
steps
one
foot on the brake
two
press the ignition to start the vehicle
three
press the defrost button
or press the trigger
inside the fuse box upon pressing the
trigger
it releases the trap cover
which in this circumstance
happens to be the ventilation system
a three-hour search reveals other pieces
of evidence
down in this tire there's electronic
scale very common in the drug
trafficking world
not so common in the auto repair
business
but the killer evidence comes from the
drug runners house just blocks away this
is the dope that was found at the other
location it was in a uh
like a thermos container
a little over 40 ounces
the drug ring is smuggling its meth in a
new and inventive way
in liquid form
it's a very simple process of
putting the liquid form instead of a
container and then adding acetone
and basically hardens it up into rock
using the runner's house as a conversion
lab the drug ring has the capacity to
make multiple pounds of meth a week
the main stash is so well disguised it
takes days for the cops to hit the
mother lode
we get an accurate weight when we get
back to the office but
roughly 10 pounds
it should be enough to put this kingpin
behind bars for life but it's no
coincidence that the mexicans are
setting up across the state line in
washington
the state of washington
if he's an illegal alien
and it's a non-violent drug offense he's
looking at a short trip to our state
prison and then just a deportation to
mexico
in that case he's looking at really
just a minor hiccup in his drug
trafficking
organizations
then start at it again
with cartel members only facing
deportation
the portland area is a soft target
and ripe for expansion
using the same supply network
established for meth the mexicans are
now pushing a drug even more profitable
and far more deadly
heroin
i'll tell you what if i kill a junkie
from an overdose my name will blow up as
a dealer and also way more dough
[Music]
it's called gunpowder harrowing
gunpowder is relatively new
scott is cooking up gunpowder a type of
heroin in high demand on the streets of
portland
the ingredients needed to make this
can be found in mexico and medicines
literally made this in their backyard
it is incredibly cheap
the mexicans are using gunpowder to
exploit an untapped market in portland
pain-pill addicts
people wanted the prescription pills but
they're super expensive those ran out so
where do you turn to
we turn to heroin
after a government crackdown in 2010 the
supply of prescription pills dried up
the mexicans seized the opportunity and
flooded portland with cheap and very
potent heroin
creating a massive market for their
deadly product
[Music]
what we're gonna do is we're gonna turn
two and a half rounds into
three and a half grams
by adding cut
scott increases his profit
you're moving two hundred bags of heroin
a day
you know you're doing about four
thousand dollars for the business today
50 of a profit
it adds up
you don't need to be the kingpin of
heroin to make a
real nice living
as i use one gram of cut
per every seven grams of dough although
scott cuts his heroin with sugar to bulk
up his profits
his business tactics are anything but
sweet it's about letting them try your
product because i got it so cheap making
my bats double the size of everybody
else's handing out free 20 bags
and when people do that to people who
haven't used before they know damn well
they will repeatedly come back to you
once they're hooked scott still has to
keep reeling in the customers
when you do get this grainy like kind of
sandy lip on your dope a lot of junkies
do like that when you get it just right
it kind of blends into where you would
never even know it was in there
and the only way you know what's in
there is when you do it and you can
taste it
oh just like hair on me
[Music]
mexican suppliers maintain a low profile
by allowing local dealers like scott to
sell their product on the streets
if you are the drug dealer who has the
good doe has the steady chance and
always has it
you are and that all depends upon your
mexican your next team to make or break
your empire
the mexicans desire to stay off the
police radar has allowed dealers like
scott to build up their own networks
but these empires are built on misery
i can tell you that the majority of my
customers are homeless kids
spend between 50 to 200 a year on heroin
i need the homeless kids of portland to
support how i live and i know i'm
destroying people's lives it's part of
the job
while those in the drug trade are making
a killing it's portland's young who are
paying the ultimate price we've both
od'd like a lot a lot a lot a lot
not to the point of death but we've both
been in the hospital a fair amount of
times because of it
you want to drive
alan here
i'm starting to get sick right now
i haven't done anything since last night
at like three in the morning you didn't
save yours for the morning no
my nose is just runny and i'm like
sweaty
ellen and ethan are homeless and broke
they've borrowed a car to race across
town to try to score some heroin
finding money for drugs is a daily
battle but ethan has a unique hustle to
keep them well a lot of what we get
ethan like tattoos for
six to eight bags a day but there's only
one dealer willing to trade dope for
tattoos ethan is desperate to reach him
you're re-upping right now
where are you at i can come pick you up
to come back
he's a new kid on the block so everybody
wants
they meet him at busy pioneer square
where the dealer delivers by bike
it's the perfect cover for drug dealing
yeah
but we have enough gas we should go
somewhere cool
ethan and ellen drive to their favorite
part of town to shoot up
this whole
the couple is part of the new generation
of american addicts
hooked on heroin after abusing pills
i did a lot of pills and then i moved up
here and i started doing heroin because
it's way cheaper
they have shared their addiction and
their drugs since meeting in rehab in
2010.
this is called piggybacking 80 i'm going
to split it to 40 so we both have 40.
years of drug use means ellen's veins
have collapsed
making them hard to hit
so ethan does it for her
as the heroine rushes into her system
ellen is released from her nausea and
cold sweats
i know i'll feel better in a sec watch
him
take two seconds to hit
that's how you do that it takes seconds
for the heroin to flood ethan's brain
[Music]
we're just sitting here feeling better
with thousands of portland's youth
succumbing to heroin's powerful allure
local police have made it their number
one priority to disrupt the flow into
the city
by smashing the local distribution
networks
this group has been delivering heroin
from salem oregon up to
uh the metro area around portland
it's sergeant robert's job to catch the
elusive runners who deliver mexican
heroin to portland's street dealers
his team has been doing surveillance on
a runner for six weeks
[Music]
today is the day they try to take him
down
but first the informant must lay a trap
portland police set up a trap for a
mexican drug runner yeah hey where do
you want me to go man
fourth and oak
yeah
um okay
okay all right you got you got that for
me though
yeah
the yeah orders two ounces of heroin
now the drug squad has to follow the
runner and catch him making the delivery
they're in salem um we're expecting that
they're going to get on i-5 northbound
to portland to start doing their
deliveries
located on the i-5 corridor heroin
suppliers have established a major hub
46 miles south of portland in salem
a lot of these runners they've come into
the country illegally
they're looking for work and i think in
most cases they're here legitimately
trying to seek a better life
it's gotten to a lot of these guys um
you know in the bigger picture the
people who are moving larger supplies of
heroin into portland they don't care
about those guys anymore than they care
about the customers if my runner gets
taken off no problem i'll get another
one tomorrow
the drug squad is hoping to take down
the whole network by flipping the runner
but this is notoriously difficult
these mid and upper level guys
they understand that they're working for
a cartel if i rat on you my family's
gonna get killed down in mexico they'll
kill my they'll kill my mom they'll kill
my wife they'll kill my dad they'll you
know kill my kids whatever
working for the cartel is serious
business
runners are responsible for any drugs
they lose
today's target may be using counter
surveillance
four unmarked cop cars are following
but if the runner suspects anything
the whole operation could be blown
something's aroused the runner's
suspicions
he makes a last-minute call to the
informant where do you want me to go
where are you now
i'm coming into downtown right now where
do you want me to go
buddy
[Music]
they changed the location on us so we're
just basically resetting in the area of
where we expect them to arrive
since we ordered up a larger quantity
they may be wanting to just do it in
what they feel is like a safer spot for
them
with four undercover vehicles in pursuit
sergeant roberts moves to take a
tactical position up ahead
they're gonna be coming up the street
right over here
all cars move in on the target
the runner is quickly detained
but he's not alone i have a code one
cover car to northeast 32nd you're under
arrest for degree of harem and we have a
search warrant okay
oh no
police need evidence to dismantle this
complex distribution network
we've got both suspects into custody
both of them had heroin in their pants
right now we're talking with one of
those suspects to see if he's going to
be willing to give up his source of
heroin
with no leads to go on the cops need to
flip them and fast before their bosses
get suspicious the second suspect we
have in custody um is telling us he's
been selling drugs for one week and he
just started a week ago helping this
other guy out the younger man is just a
trainee he could be the weak link in the
chain
he said um
that dude is the guy that with the
contacts he doesn't know the people or
the phone number
they need his cooperation to work their
way up the ladder
the runner is too afraid to talk
and the officers have to look elsewhere
for clues
[Applause]
a second unit is on standby to raid the
runners drug den in salem
[Music]
police raid a mexican drug den in salem
oregon
although the house is empty they find
much needed evidence
it's about a piece of heroin probably
about 25 grams you've got packaging
material all over the place you've got
some balloons so they are packaging up
into the smaller increments the eights
the sixteenths
um here the vacuum seal is probably what
it came in came in ounces in that they
just cut that right open and repackage
it for how they need it it's kind of
nice evidence right off the bat this
shows that the runner isn't working
alone
and the cops are on the right track to
take down a bigger network
found about an ounce of heroin
a few thousand dollars and then we've
got some cell phones and other paper
evidence along with a whole bunch of
drug packaging a scale just some of the
tools of the trade it's a good bus for
the cops but working their way up the
supply chain is a slow process
the mexicans are staying one step ahead
expanding into new markets
i'm in it for the cash because there is
so much money to be made
it is
disgusting
[Music]
lured by big money 24 year old trey has
skipped college to sell heroin full time
it took me about eight years to get this
hook that i have we on the street's
called the gold hook
[Music]
this stuff right here um that i got from
my head honcho who i basically work for
i'm doubling my money every time i sell
one
targeting the city's young population
mexican suppliers are now using college
kids to deal for them
[Music]
and it's not just the cops you have to
look out for it's the business owners
you know people seeing it hand in hand
shake their you know they're not
oblivious they know what's going on
dealing out in the open means that trey
has to conceal his drugs carefully the
reason why i carry them in my mouth is
because if i get stopped um i swallow
them
um so therefore
you know the can stop me and i have
nothing on me and that's how they come
wrapped just in you know a balloon like
that at the first sign of trouble trey
can swallow the heroine he's carrying
and that's why they're in plastic too
and tied twice so they don't break in
your stomach um they just go through
your system you just
have a valve movement they come right
back up you can pick it back up and you
sell
but his demand for his product has
soared
trey's been forced to change the way he
operates
[Music]
okay and then i'll have my girl yell for
your name
and she'll drop it down in a cigarette
pack to you out the window all right
trey is taking a step back from street
dealing
there you go
he wants the cash without the risk and
he's found an easy solution
i have runners so i'm not out there in
the public and i'm not in the public eye
i give them
six at a time one for them to do
five for them to sell
once they bring back a hundred dollars
then i give them another another six
trey's runners are college kids hooked
on heroin he saves money by paying them
in dope
end of the night there was in first
place there's just a little competition
we have um gets gets paid you know more
than the night the more his runners push
the more profit he makes
but dealing to the young and
inexperienced is risky
a lot of people tend to lie and glorify
their usage
oh no my habit's through the roof bro i
can totally handle this and that's just
all a bunch of thrown smoke up their ass
with my potent stuff they go do a shot
next thing you know
bam they're back their eyes are on the
back of their head the lips are turning
blue and those are the couple signs of
sodius
trey is pragmatic about customer care
here is something that
i think all drug dealers
should have these are
um injectable no oxen it's what the
hospital gives you when you od pump it
into your system and brings you right
out and puts you into complete sickness
[Music]
keeping customers alive guarantees
repeat business
known friends that are now in prison
because selling go to someone who dies
that person can get charged with
manslaughter and then i'm doing some
years
trey wants to stay out of jail but he's
hooked on the profit
the cash to control the power the want
that people need what i have i'm
addicted to the hustle
[Music]
heroin turns dealers into merciless
profit hunters who prey on the weakness
of others to turn a fast buck
but for those on the street escape isn't
easy
[Music]
6 30 a.m
ellen and ethan have been able to afford
a motel room for the night
i am this morning trying to get into
detox
hoping that i'm number one on the wait
list and that i'm getting into it
to get in the detox ellen can't have
opiates in her system but there are
other options
that's
adderall
and
some sleeping pills like trazadone just
some stuff to
ward off like
feeling sick
a cocktail of uppers and downers are
keeping her together
barely
and the worst of withdrawal is yet to
come
being dope sick is like
the worst flu you've ever had times like
a thousand you know junkies do anything
to avoid it
because being dope sick is just like
hell
i'm still trying to get into detox also
so i'm still in limbo and i'll continue
to be in the
if she gets in
demand is high for beds at detox centers
so ethan has to wait his turn alone 702
we gotta go
[Music]
it could be six months before they are
together again
if i can if i get in we'll see
ethan will have to deal with this
addiction on his own
his future is uncertain
if you want to get clean here
there's
lots of ways to do it
it depends on
how bad you want it and
getting your together and getting up the
balls to actually do it
ellen has faced death too many times
she's desperate to get out this is her
seventh time in detox the only way for
me to get clean is to lock myself in a
facility
treatment is the first step in a long
and painful recovery process
leaving the streets doesn't guarantee an
escape from addiction
those in recovery
are often those most at risk
[Music]
meanwhile on portland streets the cops
continue to pick up the pieces it's 1 40
in the morning and we got a call
about 45 minutes ago on uh
expected overdose in downtown portland
at an apartment building
sergeant roberts has been called to a
suspected od at a building that offers
housing to recovering addicts this
little bit of evidence we gathered from
the room upstairs it's his needles his
cooker it's brown
where he cooked the heroin up before he
shot it for those whose recovery fails
the risks are even greater they go off
the heroin they've been clean for a
while they go back onto the heroin and
when they go back they take the same
dosage
that they were taking when they were on
heroin or they'll use that same amount
their body's not used to it because
they've been clean for a while and they
overdose
[Music]
it's two o'clock in the morning and a
guy who's 32 years old is dead because
he used heroin last night
i want to hold people accountable
for
making their money off the backs of
people who are addicted
as the war between cops and dealers
escalates
the number of young casualties is on the
rise
portland city services are being
stretched to the limits
there are people they're dying
[Music]
and
crying oh lord
[Music]
you